[Music]
the lands between are ruined
mired in torment and despair
is there really anything here worth
fighting for
is there anyone worth saving
hello
is somebody there
my name is arena
i've escaped from castle mourn
to the south
my good father secreted me out the
castle but decided himself to stay
he says it's his duty
as commander
the servants there have rebelled
filled with hatred for every one of us
they've since come for every one of the
companions i escaped with they haven't
spared a soul
i
i fear for father's life
and my soul wishes that he escaped
the slaves of castlemore are misbegotten
their very existence is considered to be
a punishment
but their only crime was being born
outside of grace
so
it's no wonder that hatred has fermented
in their hearts
inspiring them to finally break free of
their masters
the next step
in a cycle of revenge
that began at castlemorn
long ago
i see
from arena
thank you
i'm in your debt
but i can't leave yet
even if the castle should fall
as commander i must remain
to ensure the treasured sword of mourn
does not fall
into the wrong hands
ages ago a lone champion fought at
castlemorn
his entire clan had been vanquished but
he grafted their swords onto his own and
continued to fight
so determined was he to claim his
revenge
and so
this became the legendary sword of
castle mourn
it was claimed by the banished knights
of godric
stolen by a misbegotten
and then passed down to you
and with it the cycle of revenge
continues
an eye
for an eye
i'm in your debt
for keeping the sword from those fallen
creatures i'm no longer bound by duty
once i've rescued arena i will spend my
remaining days with her
marina
how could this be
my daughter deserved better
the fault lies
with me
i chose duty over my daughter's safety
and
that is how fate has answered
i'll find them
the foul wretch is responsible for this
i'll hunt them down and exterminate
every last one of them
rest assured
arena
it will be done
you're a tarnished
i can see it and i can also see
that you're not after my throat
then why not purchase a little something
i am carly
purveyor of fine goods
i am of a nomadic people
selling wares as i travel
the land has been tainted by madness
since the shattering of the elden ring
it's only tarnished like yourself
who keep things from drying up entirely
let's say you're a very welcome customer
there are others of my people who yet
survive in these lands
if the mood takes you when you meet one
then offer them some trade won't you
my people
wanderers all have long been spurned by
the grace of gold
which is why we cannot settle
but instead are forced into this pitiful
unceasing journey
but thanks to that
things are not so different for us now
i think this makes us
kindred spirits of sorts
your people the tarnished
and mine
[Music]
see that no harm comes to my kin
we have a saying
we wonder us
lament not your solitude
expect no sympathy
no regard
nothing
but
if anyone dares harm us
show them no mercy
that is our code so to speak
just the way we are
deeply
unforgiving
deep within the eyes of the oldest
merchants a secret is hidden
deeply unforgiving indeed
but i've done all i can here
i'm thinking of moving elsewhere for a
time
so far we've spoken of misbegotten
banished knights tarnished and merchants
all was burned by grace in one way or
another
you can't go too far without wondering
if the golden order is to blame
for the oceans of anger and despair
[Music]
when we last met edgar he swore revenge
upon the misbegotten
but now all must die misbegotten or not
and if you defeat edgar you will receive
a shibriri grape
it's our proof that his need for revenge
no longer divides or distinguishes
love revenge
melt it all away in the yellow chaos
flame
[Music]
but there are those who fight against
the tarnished who stalk their own
yura the hunter of bloody fingers will
often be at your side
yura comes from the land of reeds a
place that has long been locked in a
miserable civil war and it's said that
the entire nation has succumbed to a
blood-soaked madness
it's not too surprising then that europe
fights against any blood-crazed
tarnished
whether they serve the lord of blood
or otherwise
but yura's true mark is a drake knight
named elianora
located at the second church of america
where she kills yura in cold blood
once elianora had a legacy as a proud
knight but because of her dragon
communion it seems her humanity has
slipped away
so you put that legacy to rest
by now it should be clear
that madness takes many forms
hello
is someone there
my name is hayeta
and i'm journeying in search of the
distant light
if i might be so bold as to ask
would you donate any shiburi grapes in
your possession to me
she looks like arena
but arena is dead
somehow this hayeta has taken over that
body
but for what purpose
she barely even knows herself i can feel
a distant light in the back of my eyes
it will lead me
to my true duty
is a finger maiden
you're not like the others who give me
grapes are you
they rest their trembling hands upon me
howling wordlessly they gently stroke my
eyes
their frail fingers
emaciated
yet still
they give me the grapes but you
seem
somehow
firmer
now i can feel the distant light once
more
that aside
i wonder what shiburi grapes really are
delectably tender and sweet yet searing
what a sight they must be to behold
of course the shabiri grapes our eyes
yellow
shriveled and oozing that's not possible
not all of those people
their own
so those noises i heard were
[Music]
the most reviled man in all of history
it all began long ago with the crime of
slander
shibriri came up with a lie
and it was so damaging so heinous that
his eyes were gouged out as a punishment
when that lie was proven to be false
we can't be sure of what was said
but what if shabriri slandered the
nomadic merchants
what if with a crooked smile he accused
them of the very crime he himself was
guilty of
saying that they had fraternized with
the three fingers and were not to be
trusted
this would explain why the nomadic
merchants came to be so hated
it is said after all that the sickness
of the flame of frenzy began with
shabriri
and after his eyes were gouged out the
blight of the flame of frenzy came to
dwell in his empty sockets
yellow eyes became known as shibriri
grapes
and frenzy started to infect the
despairing world
a madness
belongs to those who have lost
everything
ah by the way
while even we had a place to call home
once
the great caravan they called it
[Music]
but it's been lost to us for ages
i've been searching for it as long as i
can remember
and with a name like that
you'd hope they kept some fine goods
there eh
i've always preferred my own company to
that of other peoples
and i don't have any burning questions i
wish to ask my ancestors
but there's something i need to know
my roots
i want to know who i am
where i came from
where i'm headed
i hope you can join me at the great
caravan in fact
who knows what wonders there might be to
trade
if shiburi did indeed slander the
merchants
then he knew exactly what their despair
might bring
[Music]
ah
is that you over there
i've gleaned something very important
indeed thanks to you
the reason why it was eyes i had to eat
the distant light
is far and frail
so faint it can't be seen by the naked
eye but with everyone's eyes together
it appears
finally it all makes sense
i'm certain now
i will be a finger maiden
could you donate a fingerprint grape to
me
they're special grapes which only grow
on those who've been clasped by the
burnt fingers
we only know of one other who was
clasped in such a manner
his name was vike
the dragon spear
after the war with the ancient dragons
they came the rise of the dragon
cultists who earned the dragon's
affection
one of the most beloved was vike the
dragon spear a tarnished descended from
godfrey who eventually returned from
across the sea to join the roundtable
hold in hopes of becoming elden lord
to this end vike was assigned a finger
maiden and acquired the power of two
great runes
but when he stood before the thorns of
the oak tree
he realized the truth
that a maiden's true purpose is to burn
the thorns for the one who would become
elden lord
and whether it was born of love or duty
vike refused to burn his maiden
for the whisperings of shibriri had told
him of another flame
a flame of frenzy hidden deep below the
capital that could burn the thorns away
but when vike returned
smaidan was dead
did she commit suicide after betraying
her purpose
or was like captured and punished for
his treason
whatever the case
now fike's vengeful spirit defends the
dead maiden at the church of inhibition
while the real vike kneels imprisoned in
an aver jail deep within the forbidden
lands
clad in armor clasped by three burnt
fingers
this is all that remains
of the contender that was supposed to
become belden lord
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
finally
we meet
the tarnished who would be lord
oh my
why the long face
i fear that you were previously
acquainted with this vessel
well that is most unfortunate
for he is dead
as for his flesh
he gave it to me
shabriri
i hope you can make your peace with that
you were about to sacrifice something
precious
the life of a fair maiden
that you would toss into the fiery forge
only so that you may be lord
what a horrible thing to ponder
your ascendancy
requires her sacrifice
whether she wishes it or not
but how would the lord
crown so
be looked upon
chosen tarnished and would-be lord dare
to tread the path of true rigor
spare
the poor girl
and singe your own flesh in her stead
if you are prepared to show resolve
and attain lordship through righteous
hardship then heed the words of i
shabriri
chosen tarnished and would be lord
descend into the depths far below the
earth tree capital
seek audience with the three fingers and
the flame of frenzy
if you inherit the flame of frenzy
your flesh will serve as kindling
burn the ur tree
to the ground
and incinerate all that divides and
distinguishes
oh
may chaos take
the world
may chaos
take
is chaos
[Music]
incarnate
[Music]
i
cannot
die
[Music]
make
[Music]
if you intend to claim the frenzied
flame
i ask that you cease
it is not to be meddled with
it is chaos devouring life and thought
unending
however ruined this world has become
however mired in torment and despair
life endures
births continue
there is beauty in that
is there not
if you would become
lord do not deny this notion
please
leave the frenzied flame alone
and
maybe you would have left it alone
were it not for the horrors that you
found down there
[Music]
did you see
what they did to my ancestors
the whole clan buried alive
sick
maddened
husks of themselves
if you heard their moans
they're hardly human anymore
they think we worship the three fingers
that we called the maddening sickness
down upon them
well if that's what they expect from us
then that's what they shall get from us
the world of grace and his people should
have been content to see us sink between
the cracks
but to have intruded upon our solace
having broken us upon their whims
[Music]
i'll never forgive any of you
[Music]
we won't be training any longer
wait
what's that
that burn
your eyes
you've inherited the flame of frenzy
[Music]
unknown warrior
divest yourself of everything
[Music]
our three fingers
throw white to the door
[Music]
oh that's it
[Music]
the yellow flame of chaos
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please
a frenzied flame to melt away the curses
suffering and despair
and the order
entire
that's away the
may chaos take the world
make chaos take the world
[Music]
oh
it burns
[Music]
my eyes
my eyes
they're melting
thank you
i have touched them
the words of the three fingers
as your maiden
allow me to define them
all that there is came from the one
great
then came
fractures and births
and souls
[Music]
but the greater will made a mistake
torment
despair
affliction every sin
every curse
every one born of the mistake
and so
what was borrowed
must be returned
melted away with the yellow chaos flame
until all
is won again
those who gave me grapes
howled without words
saying they wish they were never born
they come their lord take their torment
despair their affliction
every sin
every curse
and melt it all away
as the lord of chaos
no more fractures
no more birth
and so it is
that an eye for an eye leaves the whole
world
blind
you
have inherited the frenzied flame
a pity
our accord ends here
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
lord or frenzied flame
i will seek you
as far as you may travel
to deliver you what is yours
destined death
thank you for watching if you want to
get early access to more videos like
this then you can consider signing up to
my patreon the money from there helped
me to invest really heavily into this
episode for example the music that you
heard during the kalei scene was
completely custom made just for this
video it was commissioned from the
hugely talented alex rowe i wanted to
take the merchant violin that you hear
in game and then evolve it into its own
soundtrack and alex did this great job
at creating a song that really elevated
the mood of this prepare to cry episode
and of course this episode wouldn't be
half as good also without the efforts of
miss pap one who came up with the
visuals and the editing ideas for this
episode and he just inspired so much of
the story here so be sure to give them
props in the comments as well special
thanks also to securodubi for showing
off carly's cut quest line which served
as inspiration for this episode as well
and thanks in general to all of the
modders and the hackers who give us the
tools that we need to properly tell the
stories of eldon ring and again thank
you for watching i'll try to do a show
to prepare to cry episode next time i
think
and i'll see you then
[Music]
you